Kate Hudson gives birth to a baby girl  that's just amazing the actress and her  musician boyfriend Danny Fujikawa are  proud parents to a little lady the pair  started dating in 2017  they made their red carpet debut in May  at the LA premiere of snatch and stepped  out again in September for the premiere  of Marshall he's the best known in a  long time in April the couple revealed  they were expecting their first child  together  [Music]  [Applause]  Dana's two sons from previous  relationships Ryder with Black Crowes  musician Chris Robinson and Bingham with  News frontman Matt Bellamy I feel the  love from my kids a lot which is so  amazing like they're I've got very  loving affectionate children because  I've raised them now that's right  [Music]  [Applause]